oh god damn look at that guy oh my god
oh god I should not have to the church
oh I'm so dad oh wow
I will admit the cosmetics or the
aesthetics of this game look nice yeah
yeah it is my good listen to me it's
been a long night I got all my abilities
now I can draw off of alleles pretty
little flower
oh man cry you look so like wow this
Christ cry sorry I'm not gonna kill you
I'm just wow oh my lord may you live
with sunflower oh hey mommy why we gotta
play with this garden come on guys let's
go yes let's go Oh God
it's turning me on summit Soaker Oh cry
look disgusting
did I cry attempt man why are you crying
stay like this forever
baby were you like it oh right now I
mean II hug Jagger how would it happen I
you you don't you do know what about you
here ya go there you go let's don't move
weird at the same time okay
all right which way to go amazing dude
I'm sorry wait again again m'kay I am
MLG let me prove it
alright Hey 1 2 3 oh yeah this what's up
this amazing you would know what he'll
yeah so we're gonna win this this is how
you win playing versus Amy's super
weight okay for me cry has a thing on
his face
maybe he's day one we need to not get I
don't even know this cry of a purple
whale over himself
yeah that's that just as I can
oh it's a jumper it looks nothing like
you cry she's way did you photoshop that
to make yourself look prettier today
there you go
again I cry I check I want to show you
something stay there okay let's do a
spider-man kiss how did you do that I
don't know when I reload he does that I
don't know hey look at this
wait you can be a sunflower
what heck what are you doing get out of
here - get out of here you company you
cafe another Carter by yourself Jack get
out of it
no following me Dixon
we should heal each other forever I
don't have heal powers I did the [ __ ]
outside don't cross the beams this is
how avatars make lobby we got across
Thank You dudes you know what this means
we cross streams bro all right this
means red zone this is very special for
me this [ __ ] we're gonna go to a girl
guys what you should do like it Chuck do
you want to stop it oh my god no guys
dang Oh for a view no one wants to be in
the middle of our stream yes
oh if you cross it you automatically oh
it's bending oh I love you so I was so
strong wind kick well the gun okay way
it's so weak it's bending on the way I
would say Jeff yeah
chomp the [ __ ] out good job buddy
oh my gosh I'm so excited oh I'm a skier
I am fine with it he ain't gay with
aegis wow you're really selling this how
much fun we're having so much too much
fun calm down is he's I need some I need
some love from from my boyfriend ya
gotta you gotta heal your buddies bro
yeah maybe
and I feels good don't it uh yeah uh
might be my skin is so smooth right now
you're getting such a tan what Felix
that's your okay your arch nemesis man
it's okay really
yeah I see him I see him but I don't
even know him I see my enemy
cuz he doesn't like you man I'm gonna
die here he's a hater I'm talkin and
just come up
don't burn us lock him down guys
oh oh oh he's home sad he's almost dead
ah oh god he's dead yeah our streams are
too strong jack their chants sucking our
beam gonna heal
no thank you got ya
look at the boss wave I'm coming all
right si more enthusiastic to get your
heels yeah there you go
sounded angry healer I'm gonna [ __ ]
kill you
yeah guys of us we got hairy hipsters
and missus they're all hipsters oh no my
God we're screwed
alright and we got this hey there baby
ah ah hey seconds we haven't seen the
Yeti yet oh no not the engine there's a
few more that shoot him in the face
nothing he does that he's quick and he
slows you down shoot your beam in his
face I love beams in place no don't let
him kill my flower
he came my flower guys frozen frozen
good
Nelson alright movie I guess a bit
overrated but pretty solid every victory
party what Oh God
it's like a faint fall or something yeah
another lovely a title everyone stick
together there it is I can't forget
against you tonight we got it survive
here what time is best thing we got
plant your best things but oh my best
things are inside harder
wait wait Otero we're leaving in 50
seconds everyone has to be in the
tombstone at
anywhere within the landing zone sorry
that seconds everyone else here is he
there
Hey oh my god
it's a or V yeah yeah thank you Dave
you're nice I know how you been laughs a
good job if date I don't really
defensive Dame no it's that guy was
selling the game does remember him he
talked I added it yeah him oh okay yeah
you know do you know I'm talking don't
try to trick me
thanks Dave you've worked for a girl
mm-hmm
twirl ever anyone know you didn't don't
yeah I can't come to work everyone I
guess it's the skinny little straw if
you don't like that and then impress him